James Franco is seemingly struggling in  the wake of his recent allegations a  source tells ET Franco's friends are  very concerned about his well-being  quote he's not in a good place they're  watching him around the clock he's  really struggling earlier this month the  actor was accused of engaging in quote  inappropriate or sexually exploitive  behavior by five women including four  former students a source says Franco has  been a nervous wreck ever since the me2  movement started gaining momentum in my  life I pride myself on taking  responsibility for things that I've done  the 39 year old address talked of his  alleged inappropriate behavior on The  Late Show with Stephen Colbert On  January 9 the way I live my life I can't  live if there's restitution to be made I  will I will make it so if I've done  something wrong I will fix it I have to